محمود البزاوي اسم بيضيف لكل عمل بينضم له
حقيقه مهما طالت دور او قصر تمثيله تعبيره
وجمله بتحول اي لقطه او شخصيه طلع فيها
ولو لثواني لمقطع بتتذكروا الناس وبتعلق
عليه وفي هذا الموسم الرمضاني بيطل علينا
محمود الوزاوي في مسلسل اولهم سوق الكانتو
بيؤدي فيه دور المعلم شحاته عم طه اللي
بيعملو النجم امير كراره واللي بيعتبروا
من اهم تجار الاقمشه في السوق وبيتعرضوا
للصراعات ومنافسات مع التجار الاخرين
حتى لو صبيان وكده رجلهم شدت وقفوا على
حيلهم بقى عندهم دكاكين وصبيان برده هيفضل
كبير السوق واحنا ما بنسيبش حقنا
في شغلنا ولا في شغل السوق نفتح لهم
الدكان عشان يمسكوا في خناقه بعض فيها كل
يوم على مصلحته اما العمل الثاني اللي
بيطل فيه محمود البزاوي فهو الصفاره
وبيكون اخر دور الاب الفرفوش جمال اللي
يعني ولد وشفيق بيسرق صفاره الملك توت عنخ
امون وبتخليه يرجع الزمن او يرجع الزمن
ثلاث دقائق والرجوع من بعدها للحاضر
واكتشاف التغييرات والمغامرات فمن القاهره
ينضم الينا النجم القدير محمود البزاوي
اهلا فيك معانا يعني خليني ابتدي اول شيء
من قبل حتى رمضان الحالي انا يعني اذا بدي
اقول لك انه جزيره غمام يعني من اروع
الاعمال صراحه وكان فعلا مسلسل جميل جدا
جدا جدا رمضان الماضي بس انا حط لنا
الفرصه نتكلم رمضان الماضي هنبتدي برمضان
الحالي وخلينا نبتدي من سوق الكانتو
تحديدا ايش اللي جذبك في هذا العمل
لا يعني انا يعني
على ذكر جزيره غمام هو مع نفس المخرج اللي
هو حسين منباوي
وانا بحب جدا اللي اللي يحس اللي حس انه
مكتشف في حاجه او شايف فيا حاجه ومصر
يغامر بها
ويظهرها يعني ويؤكد عليها
من رشحني في سوق الكانتو كان بالنسبه لي
سعاده يعني
كبيره جدا يعني والموضوع
انا بحب قوي قوي يعني يسعدني جدا الحظ لما
اشتغل في مسلسل قماشته عريضه قوي كده
بيبقى في مباراه تمثيل وفي
والمخرج بيبقى مبدع في شغله وفي ادواته
وبيبقى كل الممثلين في غيره غيره الابداع
غيره التفوق يعني
ده كان موجود في جزيره غمام وموجود
في سوق الكانت صحيح يعني هو زيي كانه يعني
فعليا زي ما بتوصفها هي مباريات بس نحن
كجمهور ما بنحس انه في تنافس بتحس انه لا
الاداء خرافي فعلا يعني ويمكن هذا كمان
دور جديد عليك حضرتك
لا هو يعني
يمكن عملت حاجات قبل كده فيها شبه شويه
ده يعني
ده انا حاسس انه قريب قوي من البيوت يعني
يعني قريب قوي من الناس والناس عندهم
دائما النموذج ده في
العائلات الموجود فيها او اديت
يعني قريب انا حابه جدا يعني
ومتفائل به يعني يا رب ابقى شرير
بالشكل ده وانجح مع الناس يعني زي ما كنت
في الصفاره لطيف برضو يعني شرير قريب على
القلب تبغى تكون طيب ههه بس
الصفاره يعني انا اتعب واقول لك انه قد
ايش انت الاب المثالي الجميل اللي يعني
صراحه الواحد هو بيتفرج على الصفاره بيحس
يقول انه ايش الاب الرائع هذا هل انت اب
رائع جدا مع ابنائك لو سالنا هم لو
سالناهم مش انت
افندم لو سالناهم هم رايهم اه طبعا هم
اللي يقولوا ده يعني بس انا اولادي ان انا
في حاجات كتير جدا ما عرفتهاش في حياتي
وبقينا في زمن دلوقتي هم عارفين اكتر مني
بمراحل كتير جدا
فكرتنا دايما عن الاب ان الاب هو اللي
بيمتلك الحقيقه المطلقه وهو اللي عارف كل
حاجه والحاجات دي كلها ما ده بيفيدنا
حاجات كتير جدا في المعرفه فانا اعملهم هم
الاب يعني اعملهم هم الكبار بالنسبه لي
وهم اللي بيقولوا لي وهما اللي انا بسالهم
مش منتظر هم يسالوني لان هم هيسالوني في
زمانهم انا غالبا يعني زمانهم مش ملم دي
قوي يعني فعشان بيننا وبين بعض علاقه
مش اصحاب قد ما هي علاقه
متفاهمين يعني دمنا واحد يعني كده عارفاه
يعني على قد بعض قوي
عجبتني جدا هذه الفلسفه بس على سيره
المشهد اللي احنا عرضناه لك مع ابنك وانت
بترقصوا ومش عارفه ايش والكلام ده كله
ابنك قال انك انت بتسوي معاه نفس الحركات
وانتم وهو صغار فهو كتب بوست حتى بيوصف
انه هذا المشهد فعليا كان بيحصل انت كنت
بتعمل معاهم كده برفع اليد بترفع ايدك
ويلا وهاتي رقص كده
ودائما من ورا مامتهم يعني يعني كنت دايما
اعمل ده من ورا مامتهم لحد ما هي اقتنعت
فبقيت اعمله قدامها عادي جدا
اه عشان اصحيهم من النوم يروحوا المدرسه
انا عارف قد ايه اللحظه دي بتبقى صعبه
شويه عند يعني فدائما اقرب من ودانهم كده
واقعد اقول لهم احكي لهم حكايه بهمس شديد
جدا لحد ما يفوق يعني اقول له طب مين حط
المشبك جوه
المحفظه بتاعتي
هيلاقي حاجه غير منطقيه بتوصله في ودنه
كده فيقول لي ايه اقول له ايوه المحفظه
بتاعتي انت مين انت
يلا نقوم بقى علشان
[ضحك]
انه الامور لازم خلاص تكون اوكي يعني تمام
وفي العالم
لا يعني انا مش مش مضبطه انا انا طبيعتي
كده انا ما بحبش يعني امارس دور الاب لاني
مش عارف يعني فكرتي عن دور الاب مش الفكره
بتاعه الاب اللي هو عارف وفاهم وكل حاجه
في الدنيا لا انا لسه عايز اعرف كثير جدا
ففرصه ان ربنا مديني اولاد بيعرفوا
وبيفهموا وشايفين كويس جدا ففرصتي ان انا
اعرف من خلالهم احسن كتير جدا انهم يعرفوا
من خلالي وحسيت انه هذا الشيء ممكن تعمله
في الصفاره
اه لا ما هو احمد امين يعرف اكرم كويس
وعرفني كويس فقال لي ما تعمل تجربتك مع
اكرم ومع البيت معي قلت له اعمل ايه يعني
من حياتك جايه بالفكره
لا هي شبه اوكي على الورق وهو بيكتب هو عن
الحكايه احمد عنده نفس الفلسفه في البيت
برضو للولاد فقال طب ما جبت محمود البزاوي
لان علاقته باكرم كمان قريبه والحاجات دي
كلها
فانا كنت مبسوط جدا وانا بعمل ده يعني انا
حاسس انها طبيعي جدا
وهو المشهد يعني حتى اللي كنت بتتكلم فيه
لما كان بيقول لك ابنك انه يعني لو انت
ليه ما تروح وتجيب لنا سياره وتشتغل برا
وتجيب لنا سياره والكلام ده كله فسرت انت
تذكره بالاشياء اللي انت بتسويه معاها وقد
ايش هي حتى بسيطه بس انه هي هذه فعلا
الابوه انك تكون موجود في هذه التفاصيل
يعني على فكره هذا المشهد انا اقول لكل
احد يشوفه ويرجع يشوفه لانه فعلا مؤثر
يعني فعلا فعلا مؤثر جميل يعني جدا
اصل هو هيكون خبرات المسؤوليه من اب بعيد
ازاي يعني الولد هيكون فكره المسؤوليه
وخبراته عن المسؤوليه والحاجات دي من اب
غير موجود ازاي
وانا جات لي فرص كتير جدا ان انا اسافر
وان انا ابعد وحاجات بالشكل ده ده حقيقي
ورفضت جدا مع انها اثرت علي جدا في في
يعني ماديا وحاجات بالشكل ده
لكن دايما كنت احكي لهم اقول لهم انا
مسافرتش عشان كذا انا مش عايز اسافر عشان
كذا انا مش هعمل كذا عشان انا مش هعمل كذا
عشان ولا انتم ايه رايكم فيقول والله انك
تبقى معنا احلى فاقول الله هم عندهم خيار
هم واختاروا فده بالتالي نجاح يعني انما
الماده اللي كنت حاجبها من بره النجاح
منقطع النظير يعني احب اقول لك انه يعني
اذا اولادك يقولوا لك لا احنا بنحب انك
انت تكون معانا وتقضي وقت معانا يعني هذا
شيء رائع يعني خصوصا في الزمن اللي نحن
فيه الان اللي الناس صارت فيه بتهرب من
بعض بس استاذ محمود انا حابه بس اني ما
يعني انتهز فرصه وجودك واتكلم معك عن
بالطو لانه تجربه مختلفه تماما المسلسل
هذا ما حد توقع هذا النجاح نجاح منقطع
النظير ايش اللي صار في هذا العمل
تجربه حقيقيه قوي
الناس شافوها لمستهم بشكل كانهم بيتفرجوا
على حاجه يعني حاجه تسجيليه قوي
وعمر المهندس اللي هو المخرج قدر يعمل
حاجه اقرب
للواقع او لتفاصيل الواقع وحتى البطل
البطل كان بالنسبه لنا جديد جدا يعني وشبه
الشخصيه قوي وشبه احمد هو المؤلف يعني
الاثنين شبه
التجربه من من طبيعيتها او الشديده احنا
مكناش متخيلين ان هتيجي كده يعني او
النجاح الشكل ده او هتوصل بالشكل ده لكن
الحمد لله مبدئين جدا وحابين جدا وعمر
المهندس مخرج عنده حس كوميدي ما كانش
موجود من ايام عم فطيم عبد الوهاب يعني
فانا ما فيش حد بيقول اف ايه خالص لكن في
ستويشن بي
هو بان رده فعل الجمهور يعني على مسلسل ما
كان معمول له كثير دعايه وكذا الشكل
والنجاح الرهيب ده واضح جدا نحن بنشكرك
جدا على هذه المداخله معانا اليوم نورتنا
ان شاء الله المره الجايه بنجيك القاهره
لانه حاسه انه من وراك في مكتبه رهيبه احب
اني افتش في الكتب يعني اللي فيها شكرا لك
كان معنا النجم القدير محمود البزاوي شكرا
لك